what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sake I'm so pumped to
be talking about the universe is
thinking we have Charles Lindsey joining
us on the show thanks nice to be here
thanks for coming on Charles thank you
I'm so poppy here this excellent been a
long time coordinating I'm glad that
this is finally landed yeah spur of the
moment / yeah perfect I agree for those
who don't watch our own Charles II was
the first artist in residence at SETI
Institute the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and is now
the director of SETI's artist in
residency program where he pairs
extraordinary artists with leading Astro
scientists he's also the author of
recipes for the mind his eighth book of
photographs where his word clouds merged
with image artifacts of art tech
consumption NDEs wildlife psychedelics
time travel failure courage and AI and
you'll find his main link in the bio
below Charles Lindsey comm as well as
says Instagram link and the link for the
recipes for the mind book alright
Charles we must start things off with
one of our favorite questions that we
love asking our guests are we really all
one I'm gonna say yes we are I don't
think there's any other answer to that
and if we're not we're in trouble well
we are in a bit of trouble aren't we so
yeah I think we probably are one and
what gives you the insight into that
observation simple observation I don't
see how it can be any other way yeah I
think the breaks come when we are when
we when we lose that connection or the
awareness of that connection but we're
gonna talk about whether the universe is
thinking us into being or not that's
coming yes yes okay so then what is the
point then of this creation of this
reality that were immersed in
I don't think there is a point I think
it's just an expression of the universe
thinking I think we're just one of an
infinite number of expressions we being
life on earth not just the the us humans
or us humans in California or or
whatever could it be a process of coming
more alive the universe creation
becoming more and more alive through all
of these yeah and some in some way of
speaking I suppose it is it's you know
listen one of the reasons that I'm an
artist right call myself an artist is
it's this some you know existential
umbrella under which almost anything's
possible it's sort of the the self
identification moniker that allows a lot
of synthesis it's what allows me to move
in between hard sciences and any kind of
expression in art and yes so from poetry
and back to being a researcher in a rain
forest or in the architects so I mean
these questions are central to what I'm
doing and and I'm looking at them from
different angles and different
approaches and I've seem to have found a
way particularly the SETI Institute to
do that to have the the freedom and the
access and the ability to think about
these questions yeah yeah I love how you
describe the synthesis between the
science and the spirit with the art with
the creation that you get to you get to
beautifully express yourself in such a
unique way that's so needed bringing
those two sides of the same coin
together and then you also you know we
also kind of endeavored into it a little
bit of this this this creation could
potentially be making all of these
experiences so that we can become more
alive it can become more alive and we
can experience all of these different
creative outcomes and explorations and
consciousness the illusion of separation
all of these things I think that's right
I mean I think we are it's it's it's not
just so we can become more alive perhaps
it's so that the universe can be
come more alive you know we're just like
the top of the broccoli we're just we're
fractal and growing perhaps it's what I
meant by we yes yes yes we the broccoli
we we the big we the big Absolut yes yes
that big one yeah I mean listen I think
you know if you across the board at the
SETI Institute these scientists are
they're asking the hard questions
they're pushing the membrane between
what is known and what isn't known what
a perfect place to have artists and yes
you know among other things I think the
artists are you know they're symbolizing
that push into the unknown and I and I
think one of the differences with
perhaps with art and and science and and
and again I'm not interested in it in a
situation where there's a siloing I'm
interested in Adi siloing where these
things merge and mix but I think that
that you know the art is asking is often
asking questions or posing questions
where science is seeking answers the
answers are iterative every answer leads
to another question and so perhaps in
the arts every question leads to another
question as well I don't know but oh I
love that but the science is seeking the
answers artists posing the questions
yeah perhaps different questions but
maybe not so different as well also the
nature of art has changed dramatically
in the last what do we call it 10 20
years there's many ways to be an artist
now it's it's obviously blossomed
compared to what would have been a
hundred you know a mere century ago and
and that's for exciting there's so many
ways to be artists so that's one of the
things actually at the SETI Institute
we're encouraging is there's different
ways of being artists some of that could
be new media and technology but not
necessarily and I'm looking forward to
diving into that I want to ask along the
way then does it feel like the root
cause of so many of the issues that we
have is our feelings of separation that
we don't feel that deep amount of
interconnectedness well I guess the
question is who
by we that means we humanity at large
much of humanity because maybe it is
that the plants and the animals all feel
constantly interconnected well you know
there's that clever you know the leopard
doesn't question its spots
one of the things I learned his you know
my 20s I started living every year with
a stone edge shaman in Indonesia it
sounds bizarre in this in it and it was
in many ways Wow but I met this this man
who was my age and and was living you
know bark loincloth bow and arrows and
one of the things I and I'm so I spent
basically about two months a year there
every year for eight years and then that
resulted my first book and I went back a
couple times and one of the things that
the animists seemed to figure out
everywhere that animism arose which is
everywhere you had early humans yeah
what does they seem to be in balance
with nature in general yeah it seemed to
be figured out in in the group I was
with there were they are neurologists
call them the most taboo ridden society
ever known but those taboos somehow led
to these checks and balances in their
relationship with the environment and so
when we talk about this separation it is
kind of strange and in some ways
pathetic that humans evolved away from
that knowledge it's it's really as
though you know intuitively we kind of
got it right the first time and then
moved away from it and then in some at
in in in some ways some humans I think
right now are moving back to it I mean
this you know you start with interest in
organic foods and going back to where
soil is alive and perhaps not using
roundup and stuff like that but a lot of
time with yeah shop shaman in Indonesia
two months every year yeah with one
shaman and one with one shot and then I
also at that time as I was more of a
photojournalist and my interest was
really in these early peoples so I spent
a summer with Inuits who were the last
legal Whalers
I was in Japan with matagi they were the
last of a thousand-year lineage of bear
hunters they used to hunt the black bear
in Japan for gallbladder you know for oh
so he's very interested in this
relationship between these early peoples
how they thought about nature felt about
it you know these people that were
really in touch and so I began that in
my 20s and I knew at that time that
those the groups living in that sort of
authentic original way we're going very
quickly you know it was and and and it's
almost gone and so I I knew that I had
to get on it and and obviously I learned
a lot being in those places and it's
influenced to a great deal kind of Who I
am and I suppose my personal philosophy
now having been with those people it's
also very interesting you talk about
separation or what we are and you know
so that's shaman I lived with was he was
a brilliant individual his whole
worldview was different than mine and
his bank of experiences was different
but that was you know that was just one
of those experiences where you where you
see really how similar we are you know
yeah that was striking Wow
okay so that was crazy so you did it
with in with Indonesian shaman you went
to Japanese bear hunters as well that
had been doing it for thousands yeah I
wasn't I spent I mean it took a couple
years to get access but I spent one
spring with the last great hunters they
were about 70 at the time so I went in
you know into the mountains with them
when they were bear hunting whoa and
they would it was very funny when you
entered there was a place where we went
it was in Akita it was in Akita
Prefecture in the in the North so you
know like Akita the the dogs of course
and so the place to the mountains where
they went bear hunting there was a river
and all the men would come down in there
and it's thought that the the main
goddess the mountains was it was an
angry woman and she didn't want she was
jealous and so she wouldn't let women
into the mountains only men so these
hunters would go down to the river and
their traditional gear before going on
the hunt with Spears and this kind of
hunting and they would all flash the
goddess they would all show their Wagner
across the river to the goddess boy just
to show that there weren't they weren't
women because they thought if she knew
that there were women coming into the
mountains you know she would be
malicious but she liked men so they
thought that you know anyway so that was
what a ritual there's so many crazy
interesting indigenous rituals like that
endless you gave also the Inuit example
of the last whale hunting yeah they were
fattening beluga whales which is you
know awful to witness and and I mean
they were not living you know in a you
know that real traditional Inuits had
been gone a century by the time I was
there in Indonesia I found it you know
very remote people that were living the
way people lived ten thousand years ago
and in Japan it was it was somewhere in
between in but there is a deep feeling
of animism like all the spirit from them
yeah I mean the thing that it animists
believe that everything is animated
right everything as a spirit from a rock
to a tree to a human and and classic to
that belief and it's it's so interesting
that that belief you know sprung up
everywhere that humans did is is this
idea that when your spirit becomes
displaced from your physical body that's
when illness enters and so the shamans
are often in this role of pulling the
spirit back to get the evil out it sort
of it repeats through so many of these
cultures yeah well there's a lot of
levels to it I think you know one of one
of the things that's that's just been
personally fascinating is is in my
lifetime to have gone from living in the
Stone Age like that for real
yes to then doing research at NASA Ames
and and all this hybrid activity and you
were in doing in the Arctic in the
Arctic as a young geologist as a young
geologist as well so it's yeah exactly
so interesting juxtaposing the living
amongst indigenous tribe and then going
and doing cutting-edge science
it's very interesting and it totally
gives us a better understanding of who
you are and how you became who you are
today and why you care so much about
these two sides of the same coin coming
into light also another thing that I
think is really important to mention is
that like another way to juxtapose like
indigenous interconnection compared to
our very deep disconnection in like our
metropolis light pollution can't see the
cosmos sure I'm not growing apples I'm
exchanging a sheet of paper for an Apple
when I take a sip of water take a breath
of air or bite that Apple I don't think
about the interconnectedness between the
Sun and nourishing that apples energy in
me eating that Apple for energy we
completely lost that process of
interconnectedness and now we have all
of the issues with that Speedos feelings
of separation the mental health issues
no more doesn't feel like there's
inclusive fitness between us anymore
there's so much more self dealing so
we're trying to fix all those things
with an inclusive stake holding and gift
economics and all this other kind of
stuff does it really do see like how do
you see that juxtaposition like the
indigenous interconnectedness and the
metropolis see disconnectedness I mean
of course we see it one of the things
that was that was you know one of my
observations when I went back to see the
those tribal people because I tend to go
I'd basically say you know I'll be back
in a year count at 12 moons and I go
back every year and one of the things
that always struck me was and and this
is not some sort of idealized you know
Savage sort of you know the noble savage
idea but when I went back the people
there were either very healthy or they
were dead you know sometimes you go back
and say we're so-and-so who was an
incredibly strong guy maybe he died of a
snakebite or virus and but they were but
they had this health and and one of the
things that's that's that's coming out
more and more now is how our micro
homeworks and of course that was
established you know our digestive tract
was established something like 40,000
years ago and then it's only in last
century even less than a century that
our eating habits changed into all kinds
of other things so that's that's very
interesting territory definitely yeah
I'm glad you bring that I mean we I mean
you know these studies you know we it
might be dirt we could be billions of
years in terms of digestive tract from
the initial sea creatures that then made
it onto land that then of course
continued having the digestive tract and
eventually monkey juice yeah there's a
big chain and if all root of much of
root of disease does start in this this
incredible microbiome then we need to be
very vigilant in the last century about
self-dealing habits of food companies a
pharma companies of it's no longer mom
that's giving you food it's now it's a
big food that's trying to give you some
of the and then you know circling back
you know I love this idea that the you
know cells on and in our body or an
order of magnitude greater than the
cells that are supposedly us right but
this is even this way of it's a very
it's this siloed way of thinking it's
still like this us and them thinking
nonetheless it's quite interesting it
does seem like and we talk about this so
much on the show that by really tapping
into the route that we think is of all
of the problems in the world by tapping
into the interconnectedness by making
more feelings of interconnectedness
around the world from both the top down
billionaires and government leaders
corporate leaders as well as the
grassroots everyday people and really
trying to make more feelings of
interconnectedness we think that that
may solve that is the route and it may
solve all of the other symptom issues
down the down the line down the water
supply well I think that it's it's a
matter of timing do we have time for
these things to you know
aggregate and have a positive effect to
overcome the very serious environmental
mess we're in right now I don't know I'm
not sure that's what we're talking about
tonight maybe we're not as though about
the universe thinking it's in sense is
that this collective consciousness is
starting to feel the acidification of
the oceans starting to feel the
deforestation I mean phytoplankton
contribute to 70% of the oxygenation on
the planet when we feel that we feel in
peril we feel in danger so then the
first thing that we do is we're like
okay alarmism how do we make sure that
we don't die and we can live a plan a
place for our children so in a sense it
is this this deep interconnectedness
that is coming more alive because of
this pressure cooker sure yeah well I
think you know the point you made
casually but I think is actually
profound is this idea that that I think
at this point we can say the majority of
humanity or we're closed live in urban
centers where they don't see that starry
sky that humans evolved with and and so
therefore the the questioning the sense
of wonder that goes with that simple
observation it's not so simple actually
it's profound but imagine it yeah
something like half of humanity doesn't
experience that pretty strange yeah on
the other hand you know electrical
lighting is pretty magnificent as well
so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so but I
don't think anybody's look at very few
people are looking at lights going you
know how does that happen and you know
you know speaking of like you know
egodeath like looking up at those stars
I mean when you're looking at the entire
Milky Way in a completely non light
polluted area is a very fast way to have
a egodeath happen or deep feelings of
interconnectedness have you had
experiences of ego death yeah of course
I mean I spend a lot of time in nature
and you know sort of the more primary
nature the better and whether it's
through that or through psychedelics or
yeah absolutely yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's actually it's it's it's I would say
it's a fairly familiar stage and what
what comes up for you when you when you
feel in nature psyche ducks
however how what comes up for you what
is that feeling describe it to us what's
just it's feeling at one with rather
than outside of the of the system you
know and so I mean ego suggests this
this separation and so when the
separation goes away it doesn't have to
be I'm an ego death sounds very dramatic
it doesn't need to be dramatic at all I
mean I also had I've had a number of
them but I had two profound near-death
experiences when I was 20 and and that
changed my life as well because that
with that was just a fundamental
comprehension that this whole deal that
is the me being alive can end at any
time fraction of a second and when you
deeply comprehend that I'd like to think
you know we live you know differently I
mean it's affected it affected me I mean
it's you know I never forgot it can you
give us a little taste of Indies when I
was 20 in the and it was my first year
of university was in Canada University
of Western Ontario and we were nearing
final exams and I had just through a
program was University Western Ontario
in London great school and there was a
program to put young would-be geologists
in the field so I decided I wanted to be
an exploration geologist because I
imagined when I was 18 and 19 what
career would take me to the ends the
world and into nature and pay me to do
it so I and I also like the the time
spans that were approached in gel I
found geology aesthetically really
interesting philosophically very
interesting and so it was the end of
that first year and I developed all of a
sudden I developed a really high fever
and my lymph nodes all went rock-hard
and I was diagnosed as having Hodgkin's
disease and so it was I just gotten this
job in the Arctic which was supposed to
start two weeks later right at the end
of that semester a summer job which also
would pay for my way through University
and so I went in and there was the first
series of biopsies in the and
the doctor said don't worry about it we
have the best radiation treatment in the
world and at the time really from when I
was 16 I picked up a sort of a tattered
book and a used book stores called Silva
mind control method and it was a kind of
meditation that was developed by a man
called called Jose Silva I picked it up
in the 70s as a teenager it was from the
60s and it I taught myself how to lucid
dream out of that book and that silver
mind control I don't know if you ever
had you know it's become something else
now I don't know but you you practice
dream control and it's a kind of
meditation that's highly visual söze and
that way it was somewhat opposite of
Transcendental Meditation it wasn't
geared to go to a null point and a kind
of an absolute quiet but rather it was
highly visual it was almost like I mean
it was I did that and and was very good
at it very quickly and and when when
computer graphics came along I felt like
I'd already been there because I'd done
so much of this visualization through
lucid dreaming anyway I decided you know
I had this high fever and the doctors
are saying it's you know gonna be fine
and I sort of said no [ __ ] I'm not
being sick and I put myself in this in
this dream state and went through a very
sort of Joseph Campbell power of meth
sequence of I mean I had it had just
four distinct parts the first one was it
was like quite coudl masks you know
Pacific Northwest Indian masks and this
dark scary scene and then I was on these
giant rollers on the ocean on my back
also very ominous and then it broke
through into this sequence of walking
through just infinite flower you know
fields of flowers very psychedelic and
and then and and I woke up out of it and
the bed was like a soaked sponge it was
really soaked and I just knew I was fine
and then I went in for the next set of
biopsies the next day and everything ran
clean the doctors were befuddled whoa
and I just said well I'm out of here so
I went you know got on a plane up to the
Arctic and then and then a ski plane and
a helicopter
and two weeks to the day from that that
that lucid dream that that self you know
Auto healings sequence which was
obviously incredibly profound yeah I was
out in this area that was just white as
far as white could be and and pretty
flat and I was out with this geologist
it was all helicopter based work and
there was a storm was coming in so the
helicopter came out to get us and the
pilot came in a little bit too close and
was hovering and had a whiteout and so
he's at full rpm we're on a frozen lake
it's just white on white and he thought
the rotor blades were coming towards us
you know full rpm loud so when he
corrected he flew he threw the blades
into the ice and the helicopter exploded
away from us
no we're standing there myself and the
senior geologist you know not a scratch
but the helicopters right there it's
been 40 50 feet away you know she had
this huge noise this profound quiet
after and then like a low buzz and we
pulled him out he survived hold on you
did oh my but anyway there was it was in
two weeks there were those two
experiences and that was Joey no I mean
I was already reading you know hermann
hesse and a lot of psychedelic related
things and and and Eastern mysticism I
mean I was already on my way who knows
where but that stuff was really a kicker
I mean that was just like you know
there's just no time to wait you got to
go yeah yeah yeah and so I mean it's you
know there's been lots of experiences
and close calls since then but that was
just them you know whoa thank you for
sharing yeah woah
and a little over you said there's no
time to wait there's you get two and a
half billion seconds or heartbeats in an
82 approximately your lifetime so what
are you blueprinted for and what is your
unique gift to bring to the world
identify that and then parse your world
to find other people and strategies to
help bring that gift forth and so let's
ask what are you blueprinted for what is
your immense dipped of always said and I
think it's you know when when I think of
that that sort of pushed that energy to
go out
and I don't think of it as something
manic but I do think of it as something
sort of consistent I don't think I have
one blueprint some people clearly do
prodigy music don't impart a
mathematician to the blueprint yeah okay
okay so these are like saying I'm an
explorer I mean I'm just I'm just a
curious you know hunk of silly putty I'm
I'm very curious hunk of silly but I've
also been able to occupy you know I mean
the geology you know there is a in it
with the with the beauty hindsight there
is some consistency
the geology allowed me to explore and
make a living and put my way through
school and then the photographs of
wildlife I made as a young geologist of
you know grizzly bears and polar bears
and musk oxen that type of thing because
we're in these areas that that humans
weren't and you know any knucklehead
with a camera and Kodachrome in it could
take some good pictures and end up
selling some of those photographs and
then right after university you know I
took off for Southeast Asia
I worked another summer I could save
about ten thousand dollars a summer work
seven days a week for four four months
and so I had ten thousand bucks and I
just went to Southeast Asia until the
money ran out which was a year and a
half and so I went and I photographed
you know with the idea of how would one
become a photographer from ideas about
photography then were very much
influenced by National Geographic and
that genre of imaging yeah which I did
in some ways and then over time you know
I you know my approaches to photography
am I thinking about imaging grew but but
the camera was this tool that basically
allowed me to get micro education in
many areas and so you know after a
couple years at which point I based in
Tokyo and mainly I was working to
Southeast Asia because I just like the
weirdest places in the world in it and I
always thought of that kind of as that
kind of that work as time travel you
know being able to go into the Stone Age
and Indonesia and India or Nepal at that
time you could go places that were like
medieval Europe and so I was very
intrigued with that and I was also
interested in trying to photograph
things that people hadn't photographed
which was still influenced by a
in the early Explorer mentality I mean I
think now what's happened and now I'm
jumping way ahead is that you know so
much the geographic earth has been
covered by photographers now it's been
covered by drones and satellites and all
kinds of things so so then at that point
if you're an explorer and if you're
making you know if you're using imaging
techniques call it photography to to
explore then what do you do and that's
you know that's how I ended up doing my
carbon camera less work and the
processing and recipes for the mind well
anyway that's a lot of information up
front
let's also then pull up some of this as
you're as you're explaining it okay so
we have here we can you were just
mentioning the carbon work sure yes okay
so this is all available on Charles
Lindsay comm you guys can find it there
yeah explain to us what what is this
well carbon is a camera-less process
that I discovered and the negatives I'm
making are very much they are a hybrid
between a kind of drawing and
photography so the the image qualities
are highly photographic but the source
image is not made with light-sensitive
film it's really a kind of microscopic
drawing that I figured out to do with an
emulsion that I developed it's something
it's carbon based it's very much like an
ink and then I did some some mucking
with the chemistry and in fact it's
actually a good thing to go to because
like the image you're looking at now
it was those images that Jill tarter the
famous you know Astro scientist saw that
led to our conversations where she then
invited me to the Allen telescope array
SETI's you know Observatory up in
Northern California
nine years ago Wow and you know we met
in New York and she saw my images and
and asked me what these were and I we
have this conversation and and you know
being Jill super generous person who's
become a very very close friend now said
you know so what can I do for you and I
said you know mrs. Carter you don't need
to do anything you're
you know you're a hero and inspiration
and and she said come on you can do
better I said I'd like to go to the
observatory so I showed up at the
observatory and I brought some really
good you know California red wine and
all of a sudden I'm walking around in
the in the array at night under the
stars with Jill tarter having
conversations about you know the nature
of life and the meaning of life and all
that good stuff and then basically that
led to me becoming the beta test for you
know the first artists ready to see what
so what an artist do yeah what is
incredible about story though grant also
what she saw this invited you up and
well and Jill's Jill's some you know if
you think about it and and and any of
the the SETI scientists that are really
thinking about we're looking for the
signatures of technologically advanced
life elsewhere which could be radio
astronomy or or optical Astronomy you
know looking for rapid burst laser or
something like this you know it's it's
also this exercise of being open to what
you don't know I mean there is a
question inherent in the SETI search I
think is that you know this would be my
language for that but it'd be if he was
hovering in front of us would we even
recognize it see him would we even right
if it was hovering right in front of us
would we even know or would we just
think it's you know cotton candy well we
wouldn't worry you know so so I think
Jill was interested in the images
because they were images of things that
she didn't know it's also very much in a
it's in a language of scientific imagery
it's it's it's it could be electron
microscopy yeah and I think some people
sometimes which is its own interesting
question you know could dismiss things
that they see is just scientific imaging
you know you tend not to see microscopic
you know micro photography on the walls
of art museums why not yeah you know is
it considered because there isn't a
level of interpretation you know is that
level of interpretation what takes
something from being documentary to art
I mean I think it is one thing one thing
when I first got a little microscope I
just remember obsessively looking at
everything under or yeah and just like
why can't that in itself be of art
that's up on the gallery walls when
people have their awareness
consciousness expanded to what something
looks like at that small of a level then
they get how things work sometimes well
I think listen that I'm at this at this
stage in life now where I'm I just don't
care very much if something's called art
or isn't or as in a museum or you know
it could be a squashed beer it's all
visually stimulating I'm not I'm not so
interested in the labels or the the
system's built around these things I'm
much more interested as we've been
talking about in Addie siloing on all
levels I love that and the D siloing on
all levels yeah exactly that's a great
way to put it yeah and those science has
gone Western science has gone in this
direction for obvious reasons not for
bad reasons of of super specializing you
know and it's not a difficult to
understand why because for research
purposes and so forth it makes sense but
that's you know there's a kind of person
whose personality and intellect lends
itself to being super specialized mine
is not that you gave that example at the
very beginning when you said on the
blueprint answer you said some people
are blue printed just for that hyper
special specialized one thing yeah and
other people are blue printed to do very
Polymathic synthesis style war right
yeah yeah that's how we the blueprints
more malleable you know yeah or more
more modular perhaps yeah so yeah like
that
I like how you gave us the origin story
of the first artists and residency
program so those 2010 then yeah that's
2010 is when I met Jill and went to the
ATA the first time okay and then from
2010 right after carbon what were the
big you know your artists in residency
projects you know because it kind of
leads you into recipes for the mind
slowly over time but takes you through
these other photo photo recipes for the
mind
is really looking at 35 years of
experience and imaging but to answer
your question yeah when I first came
into the Institute you know I was making
up as I went I mean it one it was just a
it was just thrilled and at first I was
intrigued by the access I got to NASA
Ames through the SETI Institute so I
ended up doing three projects there one
was and all of these took permissions
and my great friend Glenn bogo's who was
the historian at NASA Ames was
instrumental in developing access but I
I did a sound work in the world's
largest wind tunnel the 80 by 120 and I
really treated as an acoustic space and
in that when I was I was amplifying
sounds I'd recorded in one of the great
rain forests in the world in Costa Rica
and then playing them back through
amplifiers in this space just really
thinking about context and sound so
playing sounds from one of the most
biodiverse places on earth in one of the
least biodiverse places so that was it
was a kind of experiment it also became
a kind of performative I shot video of
myself working in there and that was fun
there was as with a lot of my work there
was also some dry humor around it and
then I am I got permission to put
several artworks in the fluid mechanics
tanks and NASA Ames and so those were
the analog tanks where the early space
shuttle models were tested and so that
was very interesting because that was
really a you know imaging observing to
imaged the motion of fluids around
artworks which I thought metaphorically
was pretty curious because we think
about you know how do ideas flow around
artwork so I was playing with that and
then I did a sound work which was called
the sound of a quantum computer thinking
which was I got permission did audio
recordings of the d-wave 2 at NASA Ames
which is really the sound of extremely
high-end air conditioning
and but but there's a there's a beat to
it and I measured the beat it was 99
beats per minute and it was really
interesting that the engineers when I
asked them about that they said oh yeah
that's the sound of the monkey running
around inside yeah it's actually a
helium pump because the processor has to
be maintained at near absolute zero but
so there's a 99 beat per minute thump
and then all these other sort of
textural sounds so that was really
interesting and then so I was working on
those things and then at the same time I
started just casually meeting scientists
at the SETI Institute for lunch or
coffee I'd say let's go and talk and
they were all very welcoming and all
fascinating and I really just had a
great rapport with dr. Lawrence Doyle so
Lawrence is a polymath he was one of the
first scientists working with the idea
of exoplanets before we've been looking
for them now of course we know there's
exoplanets around probably every star
goes to it so he was early on that and
but the the science that Lawrence did
what one we really hit it off because
Lawrence you know one of the hats he
wears this as an information theorist
and he spent time with the Navajo Navajo
famously one of the most complex human
languages you know they were the great
you know you active and code-breaking in
the Second World War so Lawrence was
interested in their language but then
also they're they're thinking about
nature so he expressed that to me and of
course that was very similar to my
interests in Indonesia with the tribe I
lived with but then we were talking
about you know very aspects various
aspects of the science he was
investigating and he wrote the
algorithms that proved that humpback
whale communications exhibits syntax
very strongly inferring the whales have
language and in fact now he has
excellent support from the Templeton
Foundation he's continuing that work
along with other work he's also working
on quantum astronomy which challenges
ideas about the speed of light really
front edge stuff also just about the
nicest man you could have
made so we have been a great person to
interview yeah he would be rate another
one and I'll tell you what the first
time I went I saw with people like this
weird you know we went to an Indian
restaurant yeah I'm very fortunate I
went we went to an Indian restaurant in
Mountain View you know buffet and sat
down and we left five hours later
basically they kicked us out and I do a
lot of audio recording I didn't have an
audio recorder that day I totally kicked
myself so one of the things that was
there was I would I mean it was
thrilling for me and exciting for both
of us is it was very much a two-way
conversation yeah you know we real there
was you know to have somebody like door
I'd say something Lawrence would say I
never thought of it that way and that
you know that was like wow yeah you know
there's something going on here the
tennis the game of tennis is really
important it helps you get to novel
exactly and so I never went and I never
go to lunch again with Lawrence without
bringing an audio recorder and and I
have a nice archive of of those
recordings and I also kept some of the
paper tablecloths because when Lawrence
starts scribbling that is like you know
that's classic classic stuff I should
add that are the archive for the city
artist-in-residence program what has now
become a program we've had 15 artists go
through and we're about to name three
more artists just a week from now 15
have went through over ten year and nine
seven years because seven I was there
that first couple so about two or so uh
per year yeah it's not so regular but
yes
okay so we're we're naming three hundred
ninety days cool but also it's going to
say the the archive for our program is
held at the Center for art and
environment at Nevada Museum of Art in
Reno which is a great Contemporary Art
Museum and a leader in the territory
where contemporary art meets topics like
climate change and biodiversity and so
forth so those those table cloth
drawings and my recordings and our you
know they're in that archive so they're
actually there and researchable these
are the always um it's so profound
learning more about you know Lawrence's
work it kinda takes us all the way back
to the interconnectedness and also it
also you're giving all these examples of
what the SETI artists and residences
are doing I just would like to hear a
little bit um would give us can you give
us some of the cool you know 15 of them
in the latter seven years you said so
like give us some of the epic
mind-blowing well one of the ones that
was that was really surprising was
Martin Willner is both artist and a full
time psychiatrist he's in New York and
the work he does is you know his art is
just pencil on paper and his mind so
when I first thought what artists would
be invited in I I was imagining with the
artists that are using technology new
media that seemed obvious that wasn't a
lock but I thought it was probably more
like that rather than painting and say
traditional mediums it's in fact the
first artists after me were a team of
three robot assists from UC Santa
Barbara and they ended up working with
John Jenkins who was one of the
principal investigators on Keppler so
the the Observatory you know the off
earth of Observatory finding exoplanets
and they did a great work which was a
robotic work called somnium where they
sauna fide data observations of EXO real
exoplanets that was very successful but
then Martin was one of the next ones and
he came in and what he does is he
basically he interviewed twelve
scientists one month each and so what
happens is in his work and he's done
this with everybody from movie stars and
rock musicians to sort of normal people
but what he did is he he worked with
twelve scientists or twelve SETI
Institute individuals and he exchanged
information with them every day of a
calendar month so they would fax or call
or text or email what they were thinking
about or a question they had or a
photograph or a sawing anything and then
he basically does these Illustrated
calendars of every day of the week but
he developed these really intimate
relationships with twelve of our
scientists so so his work was very
unexpected in
way you know I hate to sort of single
out one over another because we've had
we've had a lot of yeah great works um
more recently in fact the most recent
artists we named is Zainab al-hashemi so
she is an Emirati woman from Dubai and I
saw her work at the Louvre Abu Dhabi two
years ago when I was over there for a
conference and then happened through one
of those beautiful moments of
serendipity to be sitting next to her at
one of these grand banquets and we
started speaking and well she was very
interesting and so after the various
protocols and so on so forth that
happened for an artist who's proposed to
become an artist she ended up pairing
off with doctor mark Showalter who's one
of the great living Astro scientists of
our time was named I think more more
planetary bodies than any other living
scientist more than Galileo marks
awesome so they're actually working
together as in ABS work has a strong
interest in geometry marks one of the
world's experts on planetary rings and
they're working on a a sculpture a
kinetic sculpture for Expo 2020 and
Dubai next year and that was I mean so
that's wonderful they're working on a
big project that's gonna get a lot of
play and visibility but I have to say
when I first introduced them and this is
one of the the joys and privileges of
the position I'm in they hit it off so
quickly and they're from different
worlds and way they were just right out
of the gate they were exchanging ideas
so that was a real pleasure and that's
one of the things that happens is that
artists are recommended in general
through our Advisory Committee which is
a very strong group of people with
interest in arts and science and so the
artists get proposed and then they go
through this this you know series of
considerations but you know at that
moment when they come in and then it's
this idea well this artist might work
well
this scientist let's see and so they
maybe go out for lunch or drinks or
coffee or something and start to discuss
and so you know it gives the the artist
get an opportunity to do if nothing else
just sit down with a leading Astro
scientist and have a conversation and
then you know the similarly the
scientists are in general are not
getting exposure to contemporary artists
so they get an opportunity to see you
know to see the world through an
artist's eyes in a sense and so that so
one is potential it's it's exciting but
it's also it's been playing out and
really in really nice ways and many ways
we're doing we're just getting going
I mean we're do you know what we'd like
to do frankly is to get the program
endowed and carry on yeah you know we
have a very strong relationship with
Lucas arts at Montalvo and they're one
of our partners and so they offer
lodging and and meals but also a lot
more because they're an established arts
program
Stanford's electronic music lab CCRMA is
one of our partners long now foundation
San Francisco is one of our learners
yeah so this is this network that that
both our artists and scientists get
access to yeah so it's it's you know
it's access to a world that that frankly
logged you know these artists probably
wouldn't have otherwise what they do
with it is up to them yeah oh man I love
it I love it a little bit just love it
so much finding these really rockstar
artists from around the world pairing
them with rockstar Astro scientists and
just be able to story tell through all
different types of mediums of art just
the profundity of what's actually going
on I love it I would love for this
conversation to act as like a flag so
that we can remember that we need to
feature more of the artists and
residences right that we need to feature
more of these Astro scientists as well
sure we got to do that I mean these
people that you're listing just need
more people to be aware of who they are
anymore what they're doing and the ways
that they're creating awakening
inspirational
discoveries and content for the world so
I I'm just super in love you think bro
you know back didn't working with
Lawrence I mean the reason Lawrence was
asking about whales is because he simply
said if we cannot communicate with
advanced species that share our own
biochemistry on earth how the hell are
we gonna dock DT yeah and so then to you
know just to bring artists in to think
about different ways of approaching the
unknown even if it's only symbolizing
the unknown or symbolizing entering the
unknown there's I mean there it it's by
definition it's an enormous territory
yeah it's it's it's potentially infinite
so that's the so the program's going
well and the Institute's an exciting
place to be and now we have this big
announcement coming up November 21st our
next three yeah
artists it's exciting can't leak this oh
so pumped to hear about this and then
also also just thinking about it more to
is like oh my goodness how do we get
more of that you gave this example this
endowment of funding right how can you
get like all these multi you know
billion-dollar corporations or
universities or governments from around
the world how do you just get the more
than chump change
little charitable donations that people
are giving you we need the same thing
we're in the same boat here it's a nice
you know I mean thanks for bringing up
and for the record our our operational
budget target is 265 thousand dollars a
year it's something like six million
dollars would endow it you know so if
there's somebody else there that would
like to help yeah yeah cook free I even
wash the dishes at that level but the
potential is very interesting I mean
really it's more than interesting it's
compelling yes yes because we have these
challenges at species level we have
these challenges and we need to apply
resources and imagination and I think
you know the nature of the nature of
research science and the nature of
experimental art which is what we're
talking about is you know the attrition
rates high you know not every artist is
gonna hit a home run just like
scientists don't yeah yeah and so you
need a you
trust in a support of the system that's
going to do that research and I think of
myself as a researcher I'm it's part of
why I'm so comfortable ps/2 yeah all
those scientists are research scientists
and I think of myself increasingly as an
artist researcher they love it and I
call myself an explorer and that's true
but it's I'm really a researcher it's
what I'm most interested in yeah yeah
it's not art as commerce it's not it's
not that correct something else
yeah it's describing reality with art
and getting other people awakened and
engaged to this reality that we find
ourselves in again I love that and it's
such a cheap thing like two hundred
sixty thousand dollars for something
like this is like a no-brainer per year
it's a no-brainer it's like how can we
get way more funding for it and like you
said the endowment like anyone that's
you know that's tuning in that wants to
pass along the right people into the
setting network to help fund this please
do this is a crucial one well I mean we
weren't really interested in and also
it's you know it's participatory you
know it's not just looking for a jacket
stab people with with minds and
curiosity to come in and of course
expense and and you know I mean we're
expanding as we are but but the room for
expansion is wonderful let's now hit on
some of these okay so we we did some of
the the story of how the books of
photographs came and now we're at the
most recent book of photographs recipes
for the mind right now recipes for the
minds very it's super unique as you can
see here we're talking every single page
looks like this
and what would you say is on the left
and what is on the right so this book it
has a hundred and eight entries there's
a hundred and eight
word clouds poems if you will matched
with photographs and each of the the
language came first the written language
came first and I started dreaming these
poems five years ago so that I told you
about this Silva mind control and I've
been practicing lucid dreaming since I
was about sixteen and I keep a low power
headlamp and pen and paper next to bed I
have my whole life so I wake up in the
middle of the night and I with that
light really low I write down in a kind
of pictographic language or words or
pictures you know things from these
dreams and so the more you do it the
more you become aware of your dreaming
this is part of the lucid dreaming
practice so in 2014 I was in Budapest
and in st. Stephen's Cathedral and in
st. Stephen's Cathedral is st. Stephens
hand from a thousand years ago
supposedly that hand committed a miracle
and so and the Hat supposedly the hand
never disintegrated when he passed away
and so it was kept in a gold reliquary
as it is now and that reliquary was
taken when the Turks you know sacked
Budapest and it was taken by the Nazis
and it kept coming back so I thought
this was kind of you know humorous and
bizarre and you pay a little bit extra
money you put like I don't know what it
is it's not a euro something like that
in a box and the light comes on inside
this reliquary that lights up saint
stephen's hand it's all bizarre kind of
wonderfully bizarre anyway I had a dream
about that and and it and it led to the
sort of the precursor of the texts that
are in recipes for the mind and what was
interesting was was how it related to
food and I basically programmed myself
in the lucid dreams I mean you can learn
to sort of program the topics or the
geographies you're going to explore in
lucid dreams once you get at a
proficient level and and so I said it to
work mining basically food experiences
converse
over meals things that happened around
some of it was hunting because I was
around those hunters as a
photojournalist and my subconscious
started spitting these things out and I
was writing them down and over the
course of about four years they started
to add up to a group so I started to
mock up a book I mean that's something
I've been doing my whole life and
originally I thought I would use some of
my drawings paired with the words and
then a publisher David Rothenberg who's
a great musician and has this publishing
imprint you know saw this work in the
studio and was interested and basically
encouraged me to put it together a book
with photographs so then I started going
back into both my physical film archive
my Kodachrome from all those travels all
those decades and then all the way right
up through iPhone photos to very
recently so I picked after a long and
very emotional deep dive into my
archives because you know you're diving
into film archives you're diving into
memory I mean these are these are memory
triggers so that was a whole sort of
story in itself anyway I eventually I
edited down to a hundred and M eight
images that matched the hundred and
eight texts and and so I had that group
of photos ready to go for the book and
it was about a month before deadline and
they were in a sense straight
photographs the the rectangle was clean
and I just felt that I they weren't
expressing this relationship to memory
as as in the way that I wanted they were
too of an own format they just weren't
doing it and I had a you know and I was
thinking a lot about the nature of
memory because I would find that a
memory from 30 years ago had that you
know that word again the veracity of a
memory from two days ago
I mean curious stuff you know yeah and
so I happened to take one of these
prints that was sitting there on it on
my flatbed scanner and I was scanning it
for some purpose and something happened
I bumped the scanner perfect and the
image bent Wow and you know I've been
thinking about this idea of bending
the fabric of time-space all these
things some I mean the idea of bending
is very interesting anyway and
aesthetically I found the image quite
compelling I mean it has some of that
look of if you put a magnet near a
television or something like that yeah
so it worked conceptually aesthetically
I liked it and I went to work and I took
all hundred-and-eight photos and I
basically processed them on the flatbed
scanner so I took the you know you think
about the photograph the photograph
comes from a real place and a real
incident and it's captured on analog
film or digital it doesn't matter and
then it's printed I have a hard print
and then I scan it and I manipulate the
print during the scan it becomes a
digital file then it gets printed again
and becomes an analyst so there's all
these levels of processing and these
levels of processing have always been
interesting to me I do it a lot when I
work with sound is this processing
filtering bending stretching is
stretching the medium and ultimately at
the end of it I just I found the group
for me personally more compelling as a
group of pictures obviously I've been
around photography my whole life I think
about it a lot I think about imaging I
think about seeing and so you know
there's that book and yeah my editor and
buddy David Rothenberg loved it he has
to arrangement new arrangement with MIT
press they're distributing they really
liked it excellent ran a Kickstarter
campaign to fund it we got three hundred
percent on that boom and we went away
and so you know we're we're like yeah
thank you
yeah really satisfying and the book I
mean the I mean poetry is a very raw
medium you know it's a very interesting
thing to express oneself I hadn't before
I mean I've written lots my books would
have certainly four words and afterwards
and so now you know I have this this
this raw content so I'm as I told you
earlier I'm developing a podcast recipes
for the mind podcast around this so
there will be a hundred and eight short
episodes and in it all I'll read the the
you know one of the word clouds one of
the poems
talk about the incidents and ideas
behind it agree you know short yes yes
clips so that's I mean that's coming
very soon I like that a lot
yeah so if this is families Aloha trend
and what an interesting way to express
oneself exactly yeah whoa what a cool
story to approach just even just hitting
the photocopier and then having it yeah
yeah just hang with it yeah and play
near it
I mean you're so cool you know not to
put too fine a point on it but you're
you're literally playing with memory
exactly and the in to have it so crystal
clear and perfect is like you know there
is that tiny bit of distortion that sure
I like that it's mostly unique you know
one things I did with that it was it was
very much like improvisational music in
that when I took the print and then put
it on the flatbed scanner I usually got
the processed image the first or second
shot so I'm not somebody that would be
you know working H image 30 times the
spontaneous results were the were the
were the things that that felt the best
and so the other thing it did is I'm
taking images from 35 years of
photography different film stock
different digital base and I felt that
you know they became a coherent group
through this kind of processing as well
you know they became of one body of work
well I mean that's the hope listen you
know I'm an artist I do this thing you
know you put it out in the world and see
if it flies let's let's dive into to
some great yeah if you feel like it
would you like to share one that can I
read can I read something please
remember what random read something and
then let us know if a if there's a
correlating image available on your
website or and what is well okay so I'm
just I am really um you can fly all
except for a couple this would be you
can flash the image today I'm going to
start with this one and what is that one
called it's called upside down trout and
this would be the first time I've ever
read this in public so upside down trout
fracking viewed from 39,000 feet over
Wyoming eating cashews
reading about China topping typing on
iPhone about fracking and freedom and
myths bloated beasts sits on toilet
character in cage next to Oval Office
tweeting treason the inane the anti
wisdom the end window-seat what became
interesting after enough became enough
ping-pong wontons sympathetic sauerkraut
nano noodles looked down limbs amuck
falling up on a stick by a stream over
fire head down salt covered upside-down
trout democracy well most of that is
somewhat obvious I mean it's me looking
out the window of an airplane I do fly
some of its about a bloated beast in the
White House and and the upside-down
trout is when I was in Japan actually
with those hunters they would catch
trout and they covered them in salt they
got them and they put them head down on
a stick on a willow that they soak and
then they get a bed of coals a little
fire by the riverside and so then they
stick the stick in the middle of the
coals and the heat obviously goes up and
you get this beautiful sort of campfire
baked to salted trout very Japanese and
if you have lemon you squeeze some lemon
on it and it's it's great so I'm also an
avid trout fisherman a fly fisherman so
I love the way that you have a
completely different grammar that like
that's poetry it's a word cloud like you
said but it's just it's totally not like
our classical description tenses and and
well it has its own it has its own Kade
it's still summer yes I love it isn't
purpose I love it I love that it's
man-made listen the tools that in this
way it's words but these tools is an
artist it's sort of the right tools for
the right purpose and so it's you know
but I think one of the things that I
liked that I have the idea because I'm
just expressing and it's brand-new with
you tonight is I'd like the opportunity
to read them because when you hear me
speak the words I mean you may be maybe
the listener gets better you know sense
of what I'm doing which will you'll have
for all 108 of these
the line that's gonna be really saying
that's gonna be on Charles Lindsay calm
yeah actually it's gonna be on recipes
for the - piece for the mind but they'll
link but they'll link okay I read
another one hand horse please yes so
this is a picture I showed this this one
this camera uh-huh
this is the source image is a buddy of
mine wushu hey is a great Chinese artist
and I'll will maybe talk a little bit
about China in a bit okay but this one
is called psychoactive blue cheese so
post gringo motion tracker beta chipset
level one access enter new species blue
cheese mutated psychoactive affords
visions of one possible future more
eating more futures intertwined some
don't come back full cranial firmware
update the great recalibration an
unprotected thought hurtling forward
naive to the forest of symbiotic
acquaintances patiently voracious
intellectual calories they despise
suddenly disguising as cheese corn
hovering in space
our thoughts are neither particle nor
wave but conjured that cheesy chemical
smell apologies I have no idea what this
sounds like to anybody but myself I
still yeah yeah I mean it's the nature
of the game yes so whoa would you like
more yes give us another one
okay this is great okay so this is
friends of Mines farm cannabis yeah
that's a beautiful flower that's a mmm
Jamaican dream and that's grown by
friends of mine at moon gazer farms in
Mendocino taste buds is the name it all
doesn't work okay
Asperger's oddballs supposed geniuses
short films cooking shows request
operations so we don't desire fine wines
high fidelity music endless water
boundless freedom
tastebuds gravity smells like art
somewhat familiar biodegradable elevates
cholesterol stimulates my pancreas feeds
my mind requires antacid Stardust
mutations nonsense absurdity humility
teeters precariously along a precipice
that isn't there
moon gazer farm space monkey Jamaican
dream son grown biodynamic terpenes
cannabinoids poly pharmaceuticals happy
legal finally I could go on there's a
lot yes yes yes it's also um you know
just again just like the way that you
like story tell via the word clouds is
really cool and go in addition to the
way that you designed the photo that you
kept these photos have been captured
over 35 years you took a while picking
these having the word clouds that come
with them it's it's a really interesting
it's a I think it's a really cool a
future of us of storytelling where it's
it's a unique it's very unique yet well
and it and it really is the the language
of my subconscious I mean the way that
these things came out is how my
subconscious spit them out I mean
there's very little post editing you
know so that I mean that's one of the
the more I mean we talk about outer
space but inner space you know our
consciousness or let's talk about dream
time you know that's that's where I'm
also I'm amazed
so those things would come out and I
would capture them and they appear
pretty close to how they came out
sometimes they were longer and I'd cut
them down a little but so even me is
it's sort of you know it it is sort of
like somebody I don't know is speaking
from somewhere in between my ears if in
fact that's where that voice is coming
from but so that so there there is a
true rawness to it and so I you know I
just chose to to expose them like that
do you know for bet worse you know yeah
it's also really interesting now seeing
this as something that can contemplate
so many of the the things that we that
we mentioned initially at the beginning
of the episode there's a list of things
you know our tech consumption near-death
experiences wildlife psychedelics time
travel failure courage AI and they're
all in like you said trans-temporal
spaces I think that's so fascinating and
it's again it's just a very unique way
of being able to synthesize so many
different fields into word clouds
accompanied by photos that have a unique
spate taste to them like this is really
cool and it's all available so the book
is available to order you can find that
link in the bio below that check out
that link go ahead and order the book
that it's the Amazon link that's in the
Bible oh and recipes for the mind comm
will soon have all of you reading it in
your cadence yeah my intention is to
release one a week for 108 weeks it's
you know it's grill over two years so
I'm gearing up for that and then there
may be some other probably will be some
other interviews that's what's gonna say
it because someone else can hit the
tennis ball back about what they think
yeah I start to get it it'll hopefully
start to get its own life and momentum
defiantly yeah now teach us about um
field station so this is already up to
the fourth field station so I just as
we're sitting here tonight in November
the fourth iteration of field station
just opened at the beach Museum at
Kansas State University in Manhattan
Kansas the first one was at MASS MoCA
and Massachusetts great contemporary
Museum second one was at the Des Moines
Art Center third was at the Akron Museum
and then the fourth is at the Beach
Museum and I've shown some individual
pieces separately but the field station
is referencing the field stations that I
worked in as a young geologist and then
biologic field stations in rainforests
and
so I always loved the aesthetic of these
mobile research stations whether they're
their tents or you know sometimes
they're their containers that are
dropped by helicopter and and what's
happening in those in in there is the
the larger structure is created by these
cases that I salvaged on eBay I a lot of
the components from my artworks the
physical artworks I find on eBay for
example I found a missile guidance
system for sale on eBay a few years ago
which I bought and sort of
Frankensteined into an artwork but the
cases I found and they were used in the
Iraq and Afghanistan wars to take
replacement transfer cases for Humvees
that had been hit by roadside bombs so
they were replacement parts for the
transmission the underside Wow and the
cases were used and then you know
probably once and then they were sold
off as Salvage so I bought a couple of
them and started building artworks and
then I went back to the man that had
them near Boston and said you have Moore
and he sort of said you know son I've
got a lot more and so then I went to his
warehouse and all these cases you know
they were stacked high and I realized
that in numbers they could become
architecture so I bought I have like a
hundred and fifty of them and so I build
artworks in them but then you know they
were built to stack on aircraft carriers
something like that so then so then I
have this this walls and it's modular
and so you know so I'm creating these
these field stations but they're my
artistic research field stations which
are synthesizing ideas about science and
magic and absurdity and so the piece
you're looking at there has rare
fluorescent mineral samples that I
collected in Greenland a few years ago
and they're in chromatography column
that's a device used in the biotech
industry to put drugs with pathogens for
tests and so I've salvaged one of those
and then put in this custom UV lighting
for the rocks and and and it actually
has a sound component as well
so you know see these are things where
their their devices and their artworks I
mean they're only art there's nothing
else to call them really and so the the
the show moves the the format of what
are the walls the structure changes the
pieces in it change it but but this is
this is this mode that I'm showing in at
the moment so unique again just like
this idea that these these are
military-grade units for transport a
transporting things can be repurposed by
an artist that wants to synthesize
complex like inspirational scientific
artistic content inside of them and then
tell a story that and now one of the
pieces sort of like the if you see the
blue and red yeah one of those yes so
huh this this field station I have two
pieces that among other things utilize a
real Tibetan antique so that is a 15th
century painted panel from a monastery
in Tibet which I acquired from a
Slovakian climber and then one of the
other ones has a 19th century bronze so
one I'm a great fan of and collect a
little bit ancient art and I love the
Tibetan art and I also love that the
symbolism of the deities in it and in
this instance the that painted panel is
in with a group of seven gold-leafed
horseshoe crabs and underneath there's a
programmed LED lighting which mimics the
crabs signaling and the the lighting is
programmed so that you have something
like a visual song it's it's it's one
it's thinking about synesthesia
so you're seeing music so what happens
is it's is it's coded so that we have an
initial pulse of beat then a melody is
created and then it complicates and
and develops in the way that a short
song develops and it's randomized so
it's different every times run somewhere
between 30 and 2 minutes and I have
there's a couple friends of mine that
help with the coding I'm not a coder but
when you when you look at this thing you
can feel that perhaps these these crabs
are communicating but the the Tibetan
panel is a bit of a non sequitur in that
device so these are these are devices so
unique well I'm so curious what the
first three were well they're all there
the three field station yeah I mean
they're different works you know yeah
one of the ones that was that was funny
was we for all the works that you saw
those bear hunters I told you about as a
parting gift when I was up there that
that spring with them and that was in
the 90s they gave me a bears penis as a
gift did you tear his penis laughs a lot
like you know a piece of beef jerky with
a bit of rope on the end and this and
then this old Japanese writing and it
was in a ziplock bag so that isn't weird
enough I so I mean they had a sense of
humor but they said listen this thing is
you know they basically said you know
all speaking japanese of course they
said you know this thing is valuable so
when you travel if you go to hong kong
sell it and take the money and you know
use the money to do your work and so I
took the the Bears penis in the ziplock
bag with the with the Japanese right
good story and when it one of those you
know animal you know medicine shops in
Hong Kong and they basically laughed me
out the door because they obviously
thought this did they play joke on you
the Japanese no I don't like so they
actually I still add that's but it does
actually loop back so and then you were
like I'm supposed to get $10,000 for the
cigarette peanuts I think there's about
three but anyway but so one night when I
do these field stations I mean one of my
ideas about showing art these days is
that I don't like to preload the idea I
don't I don't want a board in front of
the show telling what the viewer what to
see what to think what to feel I think
that the the greatest gift I can offer
the viewers that they might see
something they've never
or seen before or touch or smell or
something like that and so usually in
these shows when there is that board I
mean sometimes if there's a little
explanatory text I like it after the
after the the flow of the show so so if
somebody wants to read after they can
but I don't want to front-load I want
people to go in and go what that hell is
going on here that's what I want so you
know in that list I often just on the on
the the details of the show it just
lists the components and I think it's
quite interesting to say like yeah I've
ER optic cable laser parts Tibetan panel
bears penis so in the first one we
actually the Bears penis was in one of
the cases so nobody could see the Bears
penis but you could see who was like
really paying attention because people
go in and there were a lot of things
yeah yeah and there were a certain
number of people that would happen if I
wasn't there with the curator so I was
there and they come up and go where's
the Bears penis yeah that works it was
almost like the idea of what wasn't seen
yes was every bit as important as what
was it's not like that's a new
revelation but I've been playing with
that a lot that's cool to them you know
it's very curious I think also I was
some I was doing some work at Bell Labs
for a bit I was around the scientists
there and there was a Iranian scientist
amazing young man doing work with
haptics so much and they're basically
hooking people up to fMRI and then doing
all kinds of tests and and and the way
it related is I had mentioned to him
actually mentioned one of the other
scientists who then introduced me that I
really want
I want viewers touching my art yeah you
know that that whole museum idea of
don't touch the art I mean if it's it if
it's an important painting you get why
it shouldn't touch it but my objects I
don't mind and they're totally robust in
general and so I met this madness and I
told him this and he said you absolutely
want viewers touching your artists or
like come here check this out and he
showed me his research and the
difference between you know a connection
between any person and it can be an
inanimate object or another person the
difference between touching and not Wow
it is profound yeah
you'll remember when you touch more we
touch and you know how depending on
cultures we touch when we speak to
people and so on you know but even like
an object it just you know when you
touch something you your cortex is going
red yeah and so you know I these ideas
are playing into the very station yeah
some museums it's difficult because the
it holds your at homes your focus
exactly more exactly yeah so these you
know all the end this so this is
literally something that that's come out
of mind being you know my experience in
a laboratory and learning these things
and then bringing them into these you
know as the field station ideas
developed this is a huge point is when
you're trying to mmm awaken inspire
communicate something to have something
that's physical and tangible as well or
olfactory smell I love that I do I mean
yes it's very simple stuff but sometimes
you know you walk into my these spaces
and it looks like a lab but sometimes
I've worked with like you know pine sap
that I'm gathering when I'm hiking in
the Rockies and then have just simply
heated so you see a laboratory but you
smell a pine tree you know and and the
other thing the thing I'm doing is I'm
not you know I'm not pushing any idea I
don't I don't want you or anybody else
to think what I think or feel what I
think I just want you to have an
experience and so you know this is
playing with the senses this way is very
interesting to me and IP yeah and
ultimately I mean I'm doing it I'm doing
it in a very low fine manner as some of
that's budget some of that's immediacy I
mean sounds and incredible as we all
know but it sounds an incredible medium
to work with and I think that was when
the digital revolution sort of blossomed
sound was for me was it was something
because all of a sudden you know you
could do on the laptop what used to take
tape and I mean I'm not that old but
still there was that break where all of
a sudden you know within software you
could just do incredible things with
mangling and
processing and spatial izing filtering
all those things we can do a sound and
then I also you know really I I mean I
was audio recording early but but now
although I'm an avid I'm still an avid
photographer with my iPhone but I love
the process of audio recording because
again that's a process of focus I mean
you know that when you're recording
you're paying attention yeah yeah
this also is starting to inspire me
because when you can add you know US
memory champions world memory champions
have been doing this for the longest
time but when you can add in multiple
senses into the way that you complexly
try and remember something and store it
you're way more likely to commit it to
memory and then be able to recall it
later so you're not just thinking of a
normal desert but you're thinking of
like a purple desert that is the size of
Jupiter that also smells like grapes and
then all of a sudden you're way more
likely to remember that huh and then you
can recall it later so if you add that
to your kind of like you know pitch that
when you're pitching someone something
or when you're trying to give a talk or
just these are really important things
to do and so when as an artist when
you're trying to communicate something
so profound to people let them touch it
create some sort of a scent really get
people engaged with it and then all of a
sudden people will walk away and they'll
remember it and that's really what you
know that what we want to help do with
these shows as well as we want to help
create things that that help people
remember the profound things that people
like you were teaching on the program so
you know that may be something like you
know having something really simple like
just parsing every single episode regard
for the most key points and making a
little you know five-minute reel on
Charles Lindsay's debut on simulation
and having people be able to watch that
or having people see every profound
thing that you're teaching in a
knowledge graph and be able to click
into that and see the different things
that we were talking about that were
most profound so in different ways for
people to learn the content as well this
is super important for anyone that's
trying to help inspire and awaken
through content
and okay so now I feel like boom like we
covered a solid amount of do you feel
good about can we get to some of the end
questions or do you feel alright yeah do
you feel like I mean listen there's so
much there's so much talking I know so
but just give us some another hint on
the you know so things like field
station as well as things like what the
artists and residency's what they're
doing they have it you know these are
able to be expressed sometimes through
like gallery debut sometimes through
digital dissemination and they're all
available on on Ceti for people to go
and like yeah sure if you go in on the
sediuk site and look at the artist you
can click on their links and see what
they're doing and yeah it's that's all
they're one and one of the things that I
would say which is which is very much a
projection of my interests but is you
know I'm very interested in things that
are ephemeral and I'm interested in the
arts that are ephemeral I mean I love
theater and I love live music and in and
I in a I mean this is my theory but you
know you know in in this capitalist
society we're in so much of artist
thought not only is the thing that sells
and what price it is but it's like it's
the saleable object and and that's fine
and there's lots of great objects in the
world but I'm really interested in the
ephemeral I'm interested in these in
these experiences and so you know we're
also looking to artists that are that
are working and just call it different
mediums yeah you know so I think over
time will will span the possibilities of
those mediums yeah yeah and I'm also
very interested in that as well and
that's why you know when you have
something like this beautiful capture
that's it can be as long as 35 years ago
can you somehow you know that that used
to maybe not be so recalled at one point
can you also like sometimes why do these
things recall so well in
our memory as well and how can you then
further disseminate that I'm just I'm a
big fan of that as well and there's just
certain things that why are why what do
you remember at the end of the year
what do you remember at the end of a ten
year period or what do you remember at
the end of your life and like how can
you take those things and make them
really at the the most salient part of
your being and what you care about if
you're not doing that then like you know
if the thing that you remember from that
last year isn't something that's you're
uniquely blueprinted for us as your gift
of your brain to the world then what is
it that's going on that's you know this
is more on the like we can get a deeper
into this because this is kind of in the
some of the next questions but because
there's a really you know is it the
economic machinery that's pressuring you
into doing things that you're not
actually blueprinted for and that would
could lead us into these these question
culture I mean this is you know this is
the you know the goldfish can't you know
see itself for the bowl or the trees for
the forest I mean we live you know the
American culture is you know it's it's
justified by its own existence and it's
not like there aren't people pushing at
it and looking at it and questioning it
and of course there are mm-hmm I mean
it's it's you know maybe democracy is
part of that in this culture but it's
but it's very powerful and very
consuming you know it is the dominant
culture on earth is the is American
capitalism and you know I've seen that
because particularly not from the other
end when I was going out to those
peripheries you know cultural
peripheries where you see you know and
then you know in the 80s you still had
to work hard to go out to places that
were not affected by consumerism or
advertising or American ideas you know
the American system is just one system
and I think that it it you know it is
only natural that this hyper
capitalistic systems art in general
would be that I mean how could it be
anything else I think it's you know it's
wonderful and
mandatory and beautiful to look look at
our toward attempt to look at things in
other ways yeah you know I mean why you
know this is this you know on the one
hand we're very interested in in
multiculturalism but at the same time we
have to know that the world is
culturally homogenizing yeah diversity
is interesting diversity of viewpoints
diverse yeah okay over s'ti yeah
biodiverse all kinds of diversity our it
seems to me valuable and the way to go
but so many of our yeah you know the
meant the momentum is such that
homogenous asian is is more what's
happening that could be imaging i mean
one of my thoughts you know working on
recipes for the mind was you know we all
know we live in this glut of imaging if
you're a professional photographer and i
mean a you know what sets a photographer
apart and this time when everybody's
photographing i mean that's the
challenge to somebody that would call
themselves a certain kind of
photographer yeah may be an art
photography yeah yeah there's some
something so deeply that resonates with
us about just seeing the world all as
our beautiful collective project that
we're working on and at the same time
there's these different like
permutations of cultures that are their
own little combinatorics of how they
govern how they have run an economy how
they have what they do about
spirituality and psychology and and how
they advance technology and science like
this is just a very very different ways
also of living and being and all the way
to indigenous people and like we were
talking about with animism at the very
beginning as well just completely
different combinatoric of living versus
metropolis is do you feel like we have
free will or is this all determined I
don't know that's such a rabbit hole
yeah I think like most things it's it's
not binary it's all the above mmm I
think it's some combination hmm like if
you're more aware of your own
interconnectedness to all
plus your own unique blueprint that you
have more free will and maybe if you're
more just like you know falling into the
economic machinery and falling into the
the dopamine monkey era of getting the
information to you then maybe you're
more determined I just think it's I mean
I'm again it's like I can only know it
from myself I can imagine perhaps in
others but it's it's just nonlinear I
mean I think they're times and
situations where we're just the damn
monkey and maybe there's times when
something else is going on mm-hmm
yeah I just I think it's it's a full
spectrum I don't think it's anyone
interesting yeah okay
I think there's glimpses of free will
but yeah okay maybe that's my microbiome
you gave the monkey on one side what's
the glimpse of the free will on the
other side my feet but those moments
when when improvising in music or
improvising and making art or
improvisation of any nature that that
I'm totally thinking on my feet but I
think that's part of that's that joy and
that's that excitement is that it it
feels like a new flower blossoming not
like the repetition of an existing
flower but I don't know that's tricky
yeah and then do you think that there is
a global ruling elite of humans yes well
I suppose there is but I don't think
it's as organized as that language
suggests
who do you think they are well they hide
behind corporations don't they they yeah
a global ruling elite yeah
temporary mm-hmm very temporary yeah
the decentralisation era the
psychedelics era the interconnected era
all kicking that uh that ruling elite
power out of its stranglehold yeah yeah
tough question and it's very conspiracy
theory yes but I mean they say like in
Hong Kong there's basically six families
you know six very wealthy family it's
control the place and that's one of the
reasons things are boiling right now but
we're not going we're not gonna go down
politics we don't need to do that yeah
yeah that's that's some of the crazy
stuff that you described when a couple
families just owned all of the means of
production and I mean you're gonna
experience turmoil like well no you're
not necessarily if those if those rulers
were benevolent rulers but why even that
just distribute the fruits and let
people express their unique blueprints
in a more decentralized way it doesn't
have to be oh cool we have two thousand
billionaires on the planet and let's
just make more of them altruistic it's
like no did you really have to stomp on
people's throats along the way to get
money so anyway this is another yeah
where the whole thing but yeah it's not
really it's not like I'm not paying
attention but so soon yeah like
territory of interest it's a bit yeah
it's a bit defeatist yeah yeah there's
better we're building the next world and
that those architecting those protocols
to maximize flourishing is the most
important thing to focus on so let me
tell you something more
well positive I mean you could do what
you want with the background but one of
the it's been exciting for me to last
three years is I've been working in
China quite a bit showing speaking
traveling it's all interconnected and
you know there's a real interest there
in this art tak what's called new media
territory
I'm working in but the other thing that
this happened for me is that you know I
have this interest in ancient history
and I got interested through a jade idol
I bought on eBay that looked like et
which I then found out was attributed to
the Hongshan culture from 7-9 thousand
years ago which for all the world you
know it looks like a an ET Idol but I
got interested in in probing the
archaeology of this culture through new
media through this tech art and I worked
with a Chinese artist on the first big
museum show we did where we built a wind
tunnel in a Contemporary Art Museum and
created basically as much wind as we
could with our budget and machinery but
we built seven into custom
industrialized fans that had sensors
recognizing the viewer and so they you
know the the the wind was the medium and
then we had anemometers in the space a
real-time wind data in the museum was
affecting a projected photogram fo toh
gramma tree from these archaeological
digs this yes yeah that's part of it
mm-hmm and then but one of the one of
the thrills was I think that one you
know Chinese are in general are very
educated particularly compared to
Americans and they have a real interest
in pride and they're in their deep
history and so the fact that we were
working with ideas about about ancient
history in a contemporary manner led to
opportunities to visit digs and
archaeological sites and historic
locations and and so that's been
thrilling that's very much ongoing and I
and and you know you know sort of
branching off from there but but in the
realm what we're discussing you know
China's having this this heyday of
science fiction writing a number of the
of the you know the award-winning novels
last few years in the West have been
Chinese science fiction writers and so
it's it's it's been a really interesting
place to work and so I mean one of the
things that speaks to is is sort of
where and when is the climate optimal
for certain kinds of
art and I would say you know right now
for me China is the most exciting place
and it's eager and it's more of I would
say it's more of an idea frontier than
the West right now also things happen
quickly shows that would take 2 or 3
years planning in the West's can happen
in two or three or four months and so it
can be a bit hairy but the energy around
it's you know really intense and focused
and I'm I'm very impressed by the
Chinese contemporary artists as a that's
a big generalization and I've been lucky
enough that I'm I'm you know I've been
around sort of the cream of the crop and
in general they're half my age or
younger but that's a whole that's a
whole nother aspect of thinking you know
where does where does culture flourish
and and and you know where idea is
welcomed so for all the larger politics
I mean what big country isn't
problematic you know there there is some
very interesting stuff going on yeah I
love how focused you were in that last
bit on the importance of what China is
doing in the world we just also like we
bonded on came back from those
partnership interviews in Beijing Hong
Joe and Shanghai and it's just
profoundly important for us to be more
aware about what's going on in their own
combinatorics their own beautiful
expression as well and try and identify
what could be some of the things in a
sense like we're talking about marrying
signs of spirit or science in art it's
kind of like marrying the East in the
West in many ways for a prosperous tree
that's growing out of this egg yolk
that's that we're all birthing from what
I think you know in these times more
than ever you know speaking to that you
know when I'm over there I'm I'm an
ambassador you know I feel like I'm an
ambassador for fur I hope for the best
that are you know some of the best of
what our culture offers I mean I'm a for
all the for all the challenges the Bay
Area has I mean the aggregation of minds
and in
in the Bay Area and the things that are
being discussed whether it's the front
of social media or psychedelics or or
organic biodynamic farming I mean the
areas it's happening and so then a lot
of those ideas you know to take those
ideas and and and interact and mesh with
you know our Chinese as I say artist you
know our compatriots you know I it's
it's you know I'm I'm the anti DC
ambassador over there and I think it's
really important and I'm not the only
one thinking that I mean the arts is a
very good way to interact with other
cultures yeah affair absolutely that's a
great point and I'm just loving this
some last bit on that because there's so
many different combinatoric of art
that's happening around the world and it
is a great way to engage with people
geopolitically I love that you know what
tomorrow night you gray are in San
Francisco who I'm a big fan of or the
the evening show is electronic musicians
from Shanghai mmm the early show is
Morten subbotnik I mean they have a hot
night going on tomorrow mm-hmm but
that's a place that's doing exactly that
you know they're bringing over the
artists yep what do you think is a skill
that we should know moving into this
next world well you mean is it coding I
think the skill is is one-on-one human
interaction I don't think we can ever
get good enough at that so you know
again it's just not my position I don't
know enough I don't have kids to be look
you know it's it's you read a lot of
stuff that's it's quite cynical about
people you know falling into screen
world and VR world but I think yeah I
think one on one human interaction there
there's I mean I'm a knucklehead for me
that's that's an ongoing lifetime
likewise effort and it likewise yeah you
know I gotta graduate by the end of the
game or enlightenment as well like how
deeply can you stay interconnected to
everything all the time you know it's
another one and but this kind of also
interestingly leads into the next
question which is do you think that
humans are biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence could be I'm
a big fan of sci-fi and and I don't see
why not
you know so okay so I'm gonna take that
and and and sort of pose a question to
you that's something I think about and
that is if we might imagine that
religion was necessary at a certain
stage of human evolution by definition
and if we look you know art has been
necessary it has been with us for a
great part of our evolution but if we in
the post but if if we might imagine a
post biologic us some hybrid and then
maybe a completely non biologic and if
we imagine that the systems that run
that coded systems call it machine learn
and call it AI at a certain level if it
evolves towards super logic and by the
way this idea is already basically
posited in the character of Spock if
that if that evolves to a position of
super logic is art necessary anymore or
does art all only arise is it only
necessary at this at this part of human
evolution that's that's very messy you
know that you know the ways to deal with
the inexplicable the unknowable yeah so
I sort of you know but you see where I'm
going with that I think is that if you
know we think you know arts been with us
as long as we can imagine but that
doesn't mean it will be forever I mean
we don't know what we've become I mean I
still think that you know however far
out whether it's a hundred years or a
thousand years if we survive I guess
we're gonna survive in some way shape or
form no matter how burnt the earth gets
you know that post biologic human is
still human I think yeah I think I
really like how you put it on such a big
cosmological perspective that you get to
the point where is it that if digital
super intelligence is what we're me to
do then what will if we figure out how
to embed consciousness into that digital
super intelligence we help
make it conscious although all is
conscious that could it be then that
then what is the purpose of if you can
run all of the complex permutations of
all art of all science of all different
things like what will actually be
happening at that point how Star Trek II
and will it be what exactly will it be
like it's funny thinking that 2019 or
here having this conversation
approaching 2020 and it's just so funny
that that we even use these two digits
two zero two zero to describe this time
after hundreds of thousands of years of
human evolution that we're still just
using this it's based on religion and
that you know even in several hundred
years thinking about what to actually do
with with time what people will do with
time this persistent illusion of time
more questions yeah although there's one
that yes that I think following that is
you know somebody I mean Lawrence Doyle
that I spoke about you know one of my
great friends and influences you know
thinks that consciousness exists in the
universe and we evolved to a place where
we intersect with it so not that we that
the biologic us you know the sort of
heliocentric us that we evolved to a
point to produce consciousness that
perhaps conscious you know if the
universe is conscious if the universe is
thinking then we evolve to a place to
mesh you know to would become a node and
all of a sudden we're alive within that
but it's very it's very hard for us not
to be anthropocentric yeah you know yeah
it's very difficult yes yeah yeah the
the argument is that everything is
already consciousness and that that that
that is that deep interconnectedness but
then there's also this idea that we
ourselves are evolving our consciousness
to become more and more to become more
and more aware to become more alive to
become more transform to grow more and
some spiritual leaders call these
densities that you move up in density
until then you make another cycle of
creation and that these are just all
games of creation that are being played
for it's just such a beautiful very
abstract idea that I hope can get
disseminated better and better and
awaken people to what the possibilities
are or examine you got to think that
there there is an awakening going on now
I mean look at the the boom and and
psychedelics I mean a lot of the
conversation around it is a conversation
around healing and writing the damage
but you know there is also this the idea
of the of the healthy person using the
psychedelics to get to the next level I
mean that's what I always thought of it
you know for myself so I think there
there is a you know there is a great
awakening going on I think it's much
more pervasive than we even know but
again you know the clock's ticking that
existential yeah clock is ticking so
it's weather you know yeah yeah yeah
this is a big wisdom race are we gonna
do is there ice awakened on time arena
simulation sure well what's the
difference we can tell if we are if we
aren't yes yeah we did a whole episode
on all is one simulation theory it was a
really good one everything is one these
are games of simulations that are being
played by creation bla bla it's very
interesting a simulation you know the
language in English it suggests
something that's like fake we're not
real but but that's not what's and
that's why did word dream is used also
by writing in more indigenous yeah yeah
yeah what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in this reality the
simulation
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I mean what else could be what
could be more beautiful than that yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the artist that
coded the simulation yeah that's it
that's a that's a pretty fair oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah all of creation yes right
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a yep that's
a very good all encompassing yeah answer
was that night jasmine that just was
wafted through the room oh yeah there
was some of that that just happened a
little moments ago yeah that's a good
catch
usually you got to be in the tropics for
that but yeah we're from mmm yeah that's
so interesting
Wow boom Joslin say thank you so much
for coming on the show now thank you
really what a pleasure so I feel I
should just barely scratch the surface
but I guess that's the nature of the
deal yeah thanks very much oh my gosh so
good yeah we got to a lot of the good
depths of who you are about art about
science about the importance of
storytelling about all the different
artisan residences about rested recipes
for the mind and I highly recommend
everyone to check out the links in the
bio below Charles Lindsey comm also go
follow him on Instagram go check out the
book recipes for the mind as well that
links in the bio below be on the lookout
for those podcasts that are going to be
dropped on every single one of the 108
[Applause]
recipes yeah and then so check out those
links and then also do have more
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online about the
topics that we talked about in the show
but the universe is thinking about
meshing together are in science
spirituality do have more conversations
about that everyone and also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders all the different people with
organizations that you believe and
support them around the world help them
grow help them flourish you can find all
of our links in our bio below
dissimulation Pay Pal patreon
cryptocurrency all those links are below
you can design cool merch and get paid
all its stuff below thank you or Shapiro
for co-producing we greatly appreciate
you thank you very much and also go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in hopefully
this can be used as a flag like we set
to feature more of your incredible
artists and scientists I love love love
it thanks everyone
let us know your thoughts in the
comments good night thank you so much hi
everyone peace